[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فيما قد يرى فيه كثير من منتقدي رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
وحكومته دليلا اضافيا على ما يعتبرونه
فشلا شاملا لهذه الحكومه في التعامل مع
حرب غزه وما صاحبها من تحديات سحبت
اسرائيل ومن دون الاعلان عن تحقيق اي
انجاز عسكري سحبت الفرقه ال 36 من معارك
غزه والتي تضم بوا جولاني دائ ع السيت
اضافه الى ثلاثه الويه اخرى وسلاح هندسه
الخطوه التي تاتي بعد ايام فقط من اقرار
عدد من الوزراء الاسرائيليين بالفشل في
تحقيق اي من الاهداف العسكريه للحرب على
غزه تتزامن مع ضغوط مكثفه يواجهها نتنياهو
على خلفيه اتهامه بالفشل في اداره ملف اخر
هو ملف المحتجزين فييه في غزه الذي اضطر
اثنين من اعضاء مجلس حرب نتنياهو لاعلان
اختلافهما مع استراتيجيته في التعامل معه
ودعوته الى ابرام صفقه من اجل اطلاق
سراحهم فغدا مشاركه عضو مجلس الحرب بين
جانز في مظاهره في تل ابيب دعت الى اعاده
المحتجزين واسقاط حكومه نتنياهو خرج عضو
مجلس الحرب الاخر جادي ازنكو بتصريحات دعا
فيها زملائه في المجلس للتوقف عن سماه
الكذب على انفسهم وطالبهم باظهار الشجاعه
للتوصل الى صفقه كبيره تعيد المختطفين بدل
الاستمرار في القتال بشكل اعمى وفق
تعبيره تصريحات ازن كوت ومن قبله جانس
تزامنت مع خروج مسيرات وصفت بانها الاكبر
منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه تطالب بصفقه
لاعاده المحتجزين فيخلق موجه ضغوط زادت
حدتها رساله بثتها كتائب القسام يوم الاحد
اظهرت اسيرين واسير ناشدوا نتنياهو اطلاق
سراحهم قبل ان تبث مساء اليوم الاثنين
رساله اخرى ظهرت فيها الاسيره لتؤكد ان
زميليها لقيا حتفهما في قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف موقعهم عوامل دفعت الكثيرين وعلى
راسهم المعارضه الاسرائيليه الى المطالبه
بضروره التخلص من حكومه نتنياهو التي زادت
زاد من متاعبها فشل امني جديد في الداخل
الاسرائيلي هذه المره تمثل في عمليه طعن
ودهس وقعت ببلده رعنانا شمال تلبيب قتلت
فيها امراه واصيب ما لا يقل عن
اخرين نرحب بضيوفنا هنا في الاستديو
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من غزه الدكتور ايمن الرفاتي
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن الخليل
الدكتور بلال الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه
الخليل لواء الدويري قبل ان نتطرق طبعا
لموضوع المحتجزين خاصه مع الفيديو الذي بث
قبل قليل فيما يتعلق بهذه الفرقه التي تم
سحبها من غزه نسال ما تاثير ذلك عن على
سير المعارك لا هو من حيث المبدا يعني يجب
ان نفرق ما بين السحب حده معينه لاسباب او
لفشل وغير ذلك الان هذه الفرقه تم الزج
بها بالمرحله الاولى في القاطع الشمالي
وتلقى الضربات
وهذه الفرقه من ضمنها لواء جولاني والكل
يذكر ماذا حدث مع لواء جولاني في الشجاعيه
عندما تم سحب الكتيبه 13 من هذا اللواء
ولا تسحب وحده في اثناء الاشتباك الا اذا
فقدت اكثر من 40% من قدرتها القتاليه مع
التوجه نحو المرحله الثالثه تم سحب العديد
من الوحدات من داخل المنطقه الشماليه على
سبيل المثال الوحده 162 الوحده 256 وتم
سحب الفرقه
36 الفرق الاولى في البدايه اول ما سحبت
الفرقه 36 لحاجه ميدانيه جديده الان مع
بدايه المرحله الثانيه اتسعت دائره الحرب
واصبحت في المنطقه الوسط ومنطقه الجنوب
منطقه الجنوب تم تخصيص فرقتين لها منطقه
الوسط لم يتم احضار فرقه من الخارج تم نقل
الفرقه 36 من المنطقه الشماليه بعد اعاده
تاهيل لوا جولاني الى المنطقه الوسطى بدات
العمليات القتاليه لم تحقق انجازا يعتد به
وعانت من فشل ذريع وبالتالي هنا بدات
الحاجه الملحه لتغيير هذه الفرقه الان في
هذا اليوم تم الاعلان لكن انا كمح حلل
ومتابع منذ اربعه ايام اتحدث عن سحب هذه
الفرقه وبانه سحب جل هذه الفرقه قبل هذا
اليوم لكن في هذا اليوم فقط سحب بقيه
الفرقه وتم ايكال المهمه الى الفرقه 99
لان بنيتها التنظيميه والقتاليه مختلفه
لمعالجه الخطا اذا دعني اقول في هذا اليوم
تم انهاء الانسحاب بينما تم اجراء عمليات
التبديل ما بين الفرقتين خلال الاربع خمس
ايام الماضيه وبقيت الجبهه كما هي اذا لا
يوجد تاخير تاثير حقيقي لكن هذه الفرقه
الفرقه عانت الكثير ولا بد من سحبها لا
خفاقات لكن مع ذلك دكتور بلال الشوبكي
ونحن نتابع قبل قليل وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يتحدث لم يتطرق باي شكل من
الاشكال الى هذا الحدث لم يتطرق الى ايه
صعوبات في المعركه بل حافظ على نفس النسق
نسق التحدي ونسق الاصرار على تحقيق اهداف
الحرب كما قال بل انه حتى يعتبر سنه 24
ستكون سنه حرب وسننتصر فيها كما قال برايك
لماذا كل هذا التجاهل وهذا الحفاظ على نسق
واحد في الحديث عن مجريات
الامور لانه يعتبر اي تراجع الان في
اقواله عن الاقوال السابقه التي قدمها هي
عباره عن تكذيب او تناقض مع الذات لانه في
الايام نحن لا نتحدث عن ثلاثه ايام او
اربعه ايام نحن نتحدث عن ثلاث اشهر قدم
فيها الكثير من المعلومات للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي ان هناك انجازات قد حققت وان
هناك تدمير للبنيه التحتيه لحركه الحماس
وان هناك تفكيك لقدراتها بالاضافه الى
ادعاءه الدائم بانه استعاده المحتر ازين
لا يمكن ان تتم الا من خلال الضغط العسكري
طبعا الكثير من هذه المعلومات او معظم هذه
المعلومات هي عباره عن تضليل للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي وكونه يعني يراس وزاره الامن
هو بحاجه الى ان يثبت لهذا المجتمع بانه
هو يقوم بمهامه كما يجب لذلك لا نتوقع من
جلنت ان يتراجع ولو خطوه واحده الى الوراء
مع ذلك يستشف من الكثير من الخطابات التي
باتت تقدم مؤخرا حتى من جلان طبعا بشكل
غير مباشر يستشف من خلال اعاده صياغه
المفردات ان هناك عمليه تراجع لكنها تراجع
ضمنيه يراد منها ان تحفظ ماء الوجه لمجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي وجانت ولمؤسسات الجيش
على وجه الخصوص يعني التركيز في الاونه
الاخيره على قدرات حماس لم يعودوا يتحدثوا
عن اجتثاث حركه حماس وهذا برايي مؤشر واضح
وصريح على ان جالنت بدا يدرك بشكل واضح
وجلي ان مساله اجتثاث حركه بالكامل بكل
مكوناتها السياسيه والاجتماعيه والعسكريه
مساله غير متاحه والمتاح الان من وجهه نظر
جلان ان يستمر في هذه الضربات بحيث يعيق
عمل اي حركه حماس هذا الامر ينسجم بشكل او
باخر مع اطروحات اخرى داخل اسرائيل داخل
الجيش الاسرائيلي نفسه الذي بدا يبحث عن
ضروره ان يكون هناك تصور الان اسرائيلي ل
لما هييه الاهداف التي يمكن تحقيقها لانه
القول فقط القضاء على حركه حماس هذه مساله
فضفاضه كبيره غير قابله للتحقق بالاضافه
الى النصائح من الجانب الامريكي التي باتت
ايضا تتحدث عن ضروره التعايش مع امكانيه
بقاء حركه حماس وان المساله فقط مرتبطه
بما يمكن فعله على الارض من اجل يعني
تثبيط حركه حماس عن الاقدام باي عمل قادم
وحين نقول تقليل قدرات حماس او تثبيط
قدرات حماس هذا فيه استسلام بشكل او باخر
اخر الى انهم لم يحققوا شيء وان هذه
الحركه باقيه بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني اشار
الى جمله سريعه حين قال انه اذا لم نستمر
في الضغط العسكري لن نكون في موقع قوه
للمفاوضه من اجل استعاده المحتجزين هذا
اقرار ايضا واضح وصريح انهم ليسوا في موقع
قو الان وبالتالي هو يكذب كل ما قدموا
سابقا من انهم حققوا انجازات هو تاكيدا
لكلامك دكتور اليوم مقال في صحيفه ريدز
بقلم الصحفي ر فيف دوكر يقول تحدث مع
مسؤول اسرائيلي كبير هذا المسؤول
الاسرائيلي الكبير لم يذكر اسمه طبعا يقول
لا مانع لا شيء يمنع الان من عقد صفقه
فيما يتعلق بالمحتجزين بامكاننا ان نوقف
المعارك شهرين او ثلاثه او نعود ونعود
بعدها اذا اردنا ساله الصحفي ما الذي يمنع
ذلك قالله الذي يمنع هو نتنياهو وجنت لان
مصيرهما مرتبط بهذه الحرب اذا قفت الحرب
الان هذا دليل انهما فشلا في ما وعد بها
به الجمهور الاسرائيلي نسال الدكتور ايمن
الرفاتي عن صدى هذه التطورات بالنسبه
لاهالي غزه والمراقبين
فيها نعم يعني الواضح ان في قطاع غزه ان
الفلسطينييون يراقبون حاله الخلاف الكبيره
التي تدور داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه في ظل
تصورات بان هذه الخلافات ستدفع مختلف
الاطراف في دوله الاحتلال للذهاب الى صفقه
سريعه مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهذا الامر
ربما مرتبط بعدد من العوامل خلال الفتره
الحاليه العامل الاول حاله الخلاف الداخلي
في دوله الاحتلال التي ربما يدفع الجيش من
خلالها وهذا ما سمعناه بعديد من التصريحات
التي يريد الجيش ان لا يكون فيها محل
اتهام وهذا على الجانب الداخلي وبالتالي
هو قد يدعم الذهاب خلال الفتره المقبله
الى صفقه تبادل مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وهنالك مؤشرات كبيره وربما معلومات ترشح
خلال هذا اليوم عن ان هنالك طروحات جديده
ربما وصلت ل المقاومه الفلسطينيه وربما
تطورات جديده في هذا الملف وربما هذه
الاشارات تتطابق ايضا مع الموقف الامريكي
ومع موقف الرئيس الامريكي جون بايدن الذي
قال ب الامس بانه يسعى بكل جهد
لاعاده المختطفين من قطاع غزه وهذا مؤشر
ربما يضاف اليه رغبه
امريكيه وصلت للوسطاء
بضروره يعني ممارسه مزيد من الجهود للتوصل
الى صفقه تبادل مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه
خلال الوقت القريب وهذا ايضا يتزامن مع
الواقع العسكري في قطاع غزه الذي ربما
اراد من خلاله الجيش اليوم
عن سحب عدد من قواته من المنطقه او من
قطاع غزه القول للاداره الامريكيه بانه
يستعد لذهاب الى مرحله جديده وربما هو
مستعد للذهاب الى يعني تجهيز الاوضاع او
تهيه الاوضاع لمرحله يكون فيها صفقه تبادل
مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه لكن في قطاع غزه
انا باعتقادي ان الفلسطينيين يترقبون بشكل
كبير جدا الذهاب الى هذه الصفقه وربما
الذهاب الى انهاء هذه الحرب على الرغم على
الرغم من انهم ما زالوا يرفضون اي حديث عن
تهدئه مع الاحتلال الحديث فقط عن انهاء
هذه الحرب الذهاب الى صفقه تبادل دون ان
يكون هنالك انهاء لهذه الحرب انا باعتقادي
على المزاج الشعبي الفلسطيني وايضا على
لدى الفصائل الفلسطينيه مرفوض بشكل كامل
وهذا نتيجه التجربه الاولى التي خاضتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه والفلسطينين في قطاع
غزه في التهدئه الاولى بعد 49 يوما و كانت
الحرب اكثر شده ووطئ بعدها وبالتالي هم لا
يريدوا ان يكون هنالك نهايه
لهذا الامر لكن المؤشرات حاليا داخل قطاع
غزه تقول بان المقاومه قد يكون لديها قبول
ببعض الطروحات التي تمهد لنهايه هذه الحرب
على عده مراحل ان لا يكون هنالك انهاء
لهذه الحرب في اليوم الاول لكن ربما تكون
نهايه للحرب في المرحله الاولى من ربما
وربما هذه وقعت اشارات يعني بعد بعد اذنك
دكتور نعم وقعت اشارات هنا اعود الى
اللواء فايز الدويري اليوم قناه فوكس نيوز
الامريكيه نقلت عن المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي بان الان
هو الوقت المناسب هذا تعبيره الوقت
المناسب للانتقال الى مرحله اقل حده في
المعارك وربما هذا ما يعطي الاحب ربما هذا
سحب هذه الفرقه ربما تدخل في هذا الاطار
جون كيربي ايضا يضيف نحن تحدثنا مع
الاسرائيليين يقول ل سي بي اس نيوز اليوم
ايضا يقول قدمنا لهم نصالح نصائح حول
تجاربنا في اماكن مثل الموصل والفلو يعني
كانه يقول لهم لا تكرروا تجربتنا في
الموصل وفي الفلوجه هل اذا عوده بسحب هذه
الفرقه ربما يكون توطئه لما يقال دائما عن
مرحله ثالثه اقل حده يا سيدي يعني الان
سحب هذه الفرقه كان لضروره ميدانيه هذه
الفرقه عانت وفشلت فتم احلال فرقه مكانها
سحبت 36 ارسل بدالها الفرقه
الان الاجابه على سؤالك تكون ما هي المهام
اللاحقه لهذه الفرقه اذا كانت هذه المهام
هذه الفرقه سترسل الى واحد من ثلاثه
مهام الان وكلها مرتبطه بموضوع استمراريه
المعركه هل ست سسل بعد اعاده تاهيلها الى
الى منطقه دير البلح لانه دير البلح هي
المنطقه الوحيده التي لا يوجد بها قوات
فاذا ارسلت يعني ان المعركه مستمره واذا
لم ترسل يعني انها باتجاه الحديث الذي انت
تطرحه التوجه نحو المرحله الثالثه هل
سترسل باتجاه خان يونس لا اعتقد ذلك بصوره
كبيره لوفره القوات اذا يبقى الخيار
الثالث هل سترسل باتجاه الشمال شمال
فلسطين المحتل بعد التصعيد الاخير قد يبدو
ذلك واردا ويبقى الخيار النهائي ان تبقى
في وضعيه استعداد قتالي في عمق في عمق
الغلاف وهذا ما ارجحه انها ستكون في دور
الاستعداد القتالي الان ناتي الى ما ما
طرحته حول كيربي كيربي ليست المره الاولى
وليست المسؤول الاوحد الذي يطرح هذا
التساؤل منذ البدايه كانت معارضه امريكيه
من باب الحرص على اسرائيل انها لن تنجح و
ومن ثم تم تعديل من اجتياح الى الى النار
والمناوره والان هم يطالبونهم بعدم الغوص
في رمال خال يونس لان رمال خال يونس ستكون
اعمق من رمال مدينه غزه نعم الان دكتور
بلال الشوبكي هل نحن امام
دوله مرتبكه او دوله معاقه مثل ما وصفها
احد السياسيين الفلسطينيين لان لم لم تنجح
عسكريا فيما قررته لم تسترجع المحتجزين
الوضع في الضفه الغربيه يزداد اشتعالا
ومهدد بالمزيد من الانفجار واليوم ايضا
عمليه التي جرت في الداخل الاسرائيلي
بمعنى تقريبا يعني اكثر من جبهه مفتوحه
ومع ذلك لا احد من الحكومه اساسا نتنياهو
و جالنت مستعد لايه مراجعه هل تتوقع ان ان
يستمر هذا العناد او هذا الانكار
لفتره
اطول لن يستمر لفتره طويله لانه الان بدات
اسرائيل تحاسب نفسها نحن لا نتحدث عن
اسرائيل التي كانت على قلب رجل واحد في
الاسبوع الاول تتحدث بنفس واحد وكان حتى
اولئك الذين يعني لديهم تخوفات من هذه
الحرب كانوا يخشوا من التعبير عن هذه
التخوفات بحكم انها ستحسب في اطار اللا
وطنيه الاسرائيليه ويجب ان يكونوا في
هذا المركب جميعا وحتى بيني جانس حين دخل
الى مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي كان يقدر ذات
التقديرات بانه تسامع على الخلافات
الداخليه من اجل مصلحه اسرائيل لكن ما
يحدث حقيقه الان اكبر من مجرد ارتباك وعجز
اسرائيلي عن اداره ملفات كثيره يعني كانت
عمليه اليوم تشير الى خلاف اخر يعني
بمستوى مختلف تماما كنا نتحدث عن خلافات
ما بين معارضه وحكومه ما بين اقطاب مجلس
الحرب ما بين المؤسسه العسكريه و مجلس
الحرب او جزء من مجلس الحرب الان نتحدث عن
ايضا خلافات ستظهر بشكل اوضح بين المؤسسه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه تحديدا جهاز الشباك
مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه لانه هذه
العمليه اتت بعد تقديرات من جهاز الشباك
واضحه يعني قبل يومين كنا نناقش على هذه
الشاشه ان هناك تقارير من الشباك
الاسرائيلي رفعت الى مكتب رئيس الوزراء
يحذروه من وضع الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي
السياسات التي مرست ايضا في الضفه الغربيه
والتي ينادي يعني حتى بعض الاقطاب
الاسرائيليه بامكانيه استنساخها في قطاع
غزه ها هي الان لا تحقق الامن الاسرائيلي
يعني العمليه التي حصلت ال هذا اليوم في
تل ابيب تحمل الكثير من المضامين بالرغم
من بساطتها يعني بالمفاهيم العسكريه
المضمون الاول ان الحاله النضالي في الضفه
الغربيه تتسع ولا تتقلص بالرغم من
السياسات التي تمارس من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بتقليص بتقطيع اوصال الضفه
الغربيه المساله الثانيه انها مرست من غير
سلاح بمعنى انه سياسات اجتثاث التنظيمات
الفلسطينيه وسياسات اجتثاث القدرات
العسكريه للفصائل الفلسطينيه في فه
الغربيه لم تحل دون الاضرار باهداف
اسرائيليه لانه العمليه تمت بواسطه يعني
مركبه تم الاستيلاء عليها داخل تل ابيب
المساله الثالثه اننا نتحدث ايضا عن ان
هذه العمليه تمت حتى في ظل التخوفات بمعنى
انه في تقديرات امنيه موجوده ومع ذلك لم
تحل هذه التقديرات من ردعها بالاضافه الى
ما يجري في الضفه الغربيه ما تحدثتم عنه
في موضوع قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى الخسائر
على المستوى الدولي والدبلوماسي وا وجدت
اسرائيل نفسها تحاكم الان امام محكمه
العدده الدوليه كل هذا الامر يضع الان
بنيامين نتنياهو في مازق لانه بنيامين
نتنياهو هو الشخص الذي وقف في يوم من
الايام امام يعني لوح ذكي ليقدم اسرائيل
للعالم على انها واحه الاستثمار واحه
الديمقراطيه واحه الامن وانها استطاعت
اختراق الكثير من الخطوط الحمر في السياق
الاقليمي والسياق الفلسطيني الداخلي كل
ذلك ينهار الان امام يعني عيني بنيامين
نتنياهو حتى على المستوى الداخلي يعني
الانقلاب القضائي الذي حصل قبل السابع من
اكتوبر شبه انتهى بحكم انقلاب اخر الان
لذلك المساله برايي تجاوزت الارتباك ووصلت
الى حد تفكك كل مقومات التواصل ما بين
المؤسسات الجذريه والجوهريه داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لو لو تحدثنا الان دكتور ايمن
رفاتي عن موضوع صفقه تبادل محتمله ال ال
ال
ميخائيل ميلشتاين وهو مسؤول الساحه
الفلسطينيه السابق في الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه ماذا يقول في مقال
في دعوت احرنوت يقول امامنا خياران اما ان
نعقد صفقه ونترك موضوع حماس وشانها ونكسب
هؤلاء يعودون الى الى عائلاتهم واما ان
نمضي
في اهداف الحرب الاولى مع ما يعنيه ذلك من
اثمان باهظه بشريط مثل الذي بث اليوم عن
مقتل
اثنين من من هؤلاء المحتجزين هل تعتقد بان
المقاومه انما تكثف من الضغوط في اتجاه
هذه الصفقه التي تطالب بها الكل مقابل
الكل وحتى بعد الانسحاب من من غزه كما
يقول مسؤولو حركه
حماس يعني الواضح ان الحديث عن هذه الصفقه
خلال الفتره المقبله ربما تتناسق مع يعني
ما تبث المقاومه الفلسطينيه بثبات موقفها
فيما يتعلق
بطريقه الافراج عن هؤلاء وقبل ذلك ان يتم
الانسحاب او انسحاب جيش الاحتلال من قطاع
غزه سواء في المرحله الاولى الانسحاب الى
المنطقه الحدوديه والسماح لسكان قطاع غزه
الذين نزحوا من الشمال الى الجنوب وبعوده
الى منازلهم في شمال قطاع غزه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حتى الوقت الحالي الواضح انها
تضغط في هذا الملف لتحقق مكاسب واضحه وهي
ما زالت باعتقادي متمسكه
بملف الكل مقابل الكل لانهاء هذا الملف
ولديها العديد من الاوراق وما بثته بالامس
واليوم هو دليل على انها قادره على اداره
هذا الملف بكل اقتدار وبقوه ويمكنها ان
تناور في هذا الملف وتضغط على حكومه
الاحتلال بما لديها فربما المعلومات التي
تم الكشف عنها بالامس واليوم حول مصير بعض
الجنود ربما يحرج الجيش الاسرائيلي وربما
يحرج الحكومه الاسرائيليه ويدفعها للاسراع
بالذهاب الى صفقه تبادل مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وتجاوز العقبات التي يحاول بعض
الاطراف في حكومه الاحتلال وضعها وخاصه
نتنياهو وجلن الذين حتى الوقت الحالي
الواضح واضح انهم لا يريدون الذهاب الى
صفقه تؤدي الى نهايه الحرب هم يريدوا ان
يكون هنالك صفقه من ضمنها تهدئ مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه لكن لا
يريد نهايه هذه الحرب وربما حتى الوقت
الحالي لازالت هذه العقده تؤثر على مسار
وامكانيه ان نكون خلال وقت قريب جدا امام
هذه الصفقه ربما الضغط الذي تمارسه
المقاومه قد يزيد من الضغط من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي على نتنياهو وقد يزيد من الضغط
الذي قد يمارسه جانتس وايزن كوت للذهاب
الى هذا الامر الواضح ان هنالك بقراءه
الموقف الداخلي للجيش الاسرائيلي هو لا
يريد استمرار هذه الحرب لانها تمثل
استنزافا كبيرا لديه وايضا لا يريد ان
يستمر ملف الجنود داخل قطاع غزه مؤرقا
لديه في ظل عدم قدرته على الوصول يوم يك
يزداد فيه عمل جيش الاحتلال يمثل مشكله
لديه يعني بعد اذنك جانس وازن كوت اللواء
فايز الدويري شارك في المظاهره التي تدعو
الحكومه الى التعامل في موضوع صفقه
الاران والمحتجزين اليوم احد العلماء
الاسرائيليين الحاصلين على جائزه نوبل
تشيخ هانوفر في علم الاحياء ماذا يقول اذا
لم يعد المخطوفون الان فلن تتمكن الحكومه
من النظر في اعين مواطنيها ان قضيه
المخطوفين في غزه وصمه عار سوداء على جبين
الدوله الاسرائيليه بتقديرك الى متى يمكن
لنتنياهو ان يظل معاندا في هذا الملف هو
سيبقى
يعاند مقابل اتجاهين من اوراق الضغط هل
الجانب الامريكي سيستمر في مقاربته
الحاليه الخجوله في استمرار الضغط على
نتنياهو ويلوح بالعصا الغليظه على الاقل
تقييد قدرات الامداد الامريكيه من معدات
العسكريه وهذه نقطه قاتله الامر الاخر الى
متى يستطيع ان يتحمل ضغط هذا الشارع مقابل
الاستمرار في الحكم لانه الان هو الاهداف
سياسيه شخصيه فقط لا غير لكن في النهايه
لا بد له ان يرضخ في ظل تعثر العمليات
العسكريه العمليات العسكريه متعثره وزير
الدفاع لم يكن دقيقا في كلامه تحدث عن
انقاذ 110 رهائن هو لم يقل للشعب انه تم
انقاذهم من خلال مبادره ومن خلال عمليه
تفاوض ولكنه لم ينقذ حتى رهينه واحده اذا
هو نوع من المكابره لابد ان يزداد الضغط
من الشارع ومن انشقاق مجلس الحرب ومن
الجانب الامريكي ودما تحدث قبل قليل وكانه
حررهم بالقوه كانه حررهم بالقوه هو شكرا
جزيلا لك اللواء فايز الدويري شكرا لضيفنا
من الخليل الدكتور بلال الشوبكي شكرا
لضيفنا من غزه الدكتور ايمن الرفاتي بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد غدا باذن الله في
تمام الثامنه والصف بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
لمتابعه اخر التطورات ما زالت تغطيتنا
مستمره سواء في جانبها الميداني او في
تطوراتها السياسيه خاصه وان اليوم كان
حافلا بالتطورات سواء شريط المتعلق
بالرهان والمحتجزين او بالتطورات التي
حصلت في الداخل الاسرائيلي مع استمرار
الوضع المتفجر في الضفه الغربيه